[Music]
it's starting to [ __ ] stare now he's
starting to spiral well Marsh thank you
for the setup let's talk about spiraling
what do you say how what do you say
before before the break we do a little
photographer holy [ __ ] what's going on
with Adam sessler dude he is [ __ ]
worse off he blocked me but he's he's
losing his goddamn mind on Twitter
here's just some excerpts you can see
now for those who don't know Adam
sessler uh was the host of X play on G4
TV always has been the host of X play it
was him and Morgan Webb that review
video games whatever when the frost
thing happened which again you guys
should know by now but the frosting is
that that
pink-haired woke [ __ ] that thing sexism
and gaming and everyone just stopped
watching D4 again after they came back
Adam sluster backed her up completely
completely backed her up said she's
right and doesn't matter and guys suck
and of course now G4 is not a station
anymore
but again for the second time and in
record time and you know what sucked if
it would have never come back everybody
merch and I were talking about for the
show would have remembered it fondly oh
remember attack of the show bro that
[ __ ] was dull
reboot are you happy right yourselves do
you know what the worst part of G4 was
Adam sussler honestly he might be right
honestly virgin you might be right he's
a guy to clung to his identity from his
days he's one of those guys that just
he's a Sam Roberts type like where he
just stayed for so long that eventually
when the new crop came in he was like
the senior guy and then he's the guy
that's around I don't know much about
Adam sessler I was Jeep I watched G4 a
little bit back in the day but not like
I wouldn't consider myself a fan of G4
like I know you would consider yourself
a fan of Olivia Munn I used to watch no
and not abroad oh the other broad uh
Morgan Webb Morgan Webb yeah Morgan Webb
let me tell you something Olivia here's
my thing Olivia Munn was always oh the
hottest girl on there but I'll say this
right now
Morgan Webb with her orangutang arms
would [ __ ] you way better guarantee of
credit and I say orangutan arms with
love he means that lovingly if you need
proof of that just go look up any of the
segments on Attack of the show where
they had a sex therapist on and Morgan
Webb would immediately bend over in a
chair and talk about how she liked to
get [ __ ] from dude she's so hard so
anyway as I was getting Morgan Webb's
arms are so long if she was wearing
cargo pants she could read the cargo
pants standing straight up that's how
long her arms are sorry go ahead murder
um she could literally she could
literally put her foot down a stair and
then tie her shoe
she needs to because if not she has to
bend her elbows
and we're saying this thing we love her
by the way yes but I remember this I
remember looking at this and I remember
even when this came out originally I
remember going like man she got some
long arms
[ __ ] is touching her kneecap I know oh
my God
gee anyway sorry [ __ ] [ __ ] she's
like doing jumping jacks knocking the
ceiling fan down in the gym
and it's extra funny because she has
normal woman hands too so yeah it sounds
weird yeah
[Laughter]
but she but again we say that with all
do love due respect yeah uh so anyway
yeah am I getting the I just as Adam
sessler guy I didn't know much of him
except when they rebooted it and they're
like oh he's one of the OG guys and I'm
like oh yeah I guess and then I only
know him for spiraling that's like
because this isn't his first
or is it last no remember when he said
he hoped people that people were
unvaccinated suffered during covid
suffered and died I suffered nine just
died yeah suffered and died during covet
I remember that
um I remember the same thing the Trump
people are [ __ ] Nazis and fascism and
all your typical all your left-wing
[ __ ] talking points now this is one
of the tweets so I had one hell of a
therapy session Ransom math and the
novelty of when I started on ZT ZD TV
which was what it was called before G4
TV uh with a nascent internet and I
think I might have been one of the
longest records for consistent online
hate not the most nothing to be proud of
but but Humanity wow victim immediately
let's see what else he has to say
here we go and by the way these are
these are he blocks anybody that has a
decent following but anybody with like
300 followers or something he completely
tries to eviscerate them
uh most grown men work out feelings on
our own you are you're just one of those
that knows I'm sorry I'm sorry you have
to read the there that yeah that's in
response to the therapy session my bad I
[ __ ] up yeah you did [ __ ] up you you
were right you were right you were right
and I [ __ ] up it was absolutely
correct I'm a piece of [ __ ] I [ __ ] up
what happened I nothing nothing happened
you were right I'm [ __ ] up by telling
you I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up I have
feelings uh to buzz I yeah uh I have a
feeling to bust your ass but you're in
Panama City which is punishment enough
truly the most disgusting place I've
seen first time I heard the word uh dark
as code for black people I thought they
had electricity problem at first so now
he's shooting on Florida in Panama City
um where does Adam sessler live he was
also [ __ ] on West Virginia he [ __ ]
on anything that was right leaning uh
you little [ __ ] all I got is people I'm
ready to turn the cap around my head let
me know who you are I actually came up
with [ __ ] was hard plus she [ __ ] like
you just hide and yell by the way Adam
sessler blocked me I just want to be
clear here this guy who's talking tough
to all these little 200 followers Adam
sessler blocked me and he blocks anybody
that could pose any sort of real
legitimate challenge to him Adam sessler
is a left-wing Ben Shapiro who's gonna
pick on [ __ ] you know nobody's on the
internet and block anybody who could
hold any legitimate threat to him
because he's a small man and he's
small-minded and he's played video games
his entire [ __ ] life and then the
people that gave him a career he
immediately [ __ ] in their face and
called them all in cells to sacrifice it
all to have one last run on [ __ ] G4
TV but it's okay because he tweeted out
earlier that I don't need to work I
don't have the sweet here but I don't
need to work I have several Investments
I saw that I don't need he's doing the
Opie he's the oh he's doing the Opie now
is what he's doing and the last one big
shout out tonight to those that run G4
Kanye uh for making my life more
miserable than usual when I have barely
been working for them in the first place
in for a penny in for a pound for your
[ __ ] now to give pessie credit he
retwitted it retweeted him and he goes
wow man that's kind of anti-Semitic
wow
I can't but if you see this tweet it's
on his timeline make sure you call him
anti-semitic what did he mean people
that run G4
etc etc you guys watch us you're pretty
[ __ ] smart you'll figure it out but
you know what I hate about people like
him
even worse than like you know there have
been plenty of people out there that get
People canceled that you know uh get
attacked online or whatever and cry
victim and get somebody in trouble over
it and uh you know obviously that's
abort Behavior but this is even worse
because these are people like Adam
sessler and like a certain person whose
name starts with a K who I will not say
on their show because no no I'm not
getting out of that [ __ ] War uh but
there are people out there his name is
Pepsi you don't have to call him that
word
us Christ uh but there are a lot of
people out there who make their entire
life about fighting and attacking people
all day long but then when they get
attacked it becomes I had to go to a
therapy session today how about some
Humanity folks well now you pieces of
[ __ ] in Panama City where you sub-human
West Virginia [ __ ] Hillbillies you
cousin [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] I went to
Panama City everybody had a WCW Nitro
shirt on yeah you piece of garbage how
about this
I met everyone from Los Angeles Chicago
all right New York and Miami
how about some Humanity
South Carolina not you get out of here
[ __ ] Hillbillies it's just in the
same breath and you're like I know
that's what I eat I don't even hate
cancel culture people as much as I hate
people like this because they will all
day long go after you and go yeah well I
hope your [ __ ] wife dies because you
can get [ __ ] vaccinated you piece of
garbage and then you're like hey man and
then like you say something shitty back
and they're like at Twitter safety and
you're like you said you hope my wife
got [ __ ] [ __ ] cancer because she
didn't get the jab like yeah dude okay
so I called you a piece of [ __ ] whatever
I called you the gay esler and they're
like Twitter safety
now I'm old and comfortable this is
pretty much unknown to some uh retainer
inhalers nerds
uh I have other Investments than a job
I'm out of the game until I'm interested
for now and I'm not interested
um
it's really weird that a dude who uh
whose entire claim to fame is being on a
network that talks about video games
exclusively oh my God beating around the
bush to call somebody a [ __ ] nerd
he's making your mama jokes did you see
that of course that's all he does here's
another one no he does like your mom
said I wasn't obscure he is yeah he's
doing your mom thing a lot are you all
from West Virginia or something and
think you have to abide by what the boss
tells you to get his currency yeah he's
like that you [ __ ] coal mine and
he'll hear that that's a [ __ ] see what
Adam sessler thinks of you you you're
[ __ ] Midwest people grow our food and
shut the [ __ ] up exactly
sure you guys want to giggle when you
Google search where does Adam sessler
live it auto corrects you where does
Adam Sandler live
yeah because nobody gives a [ __ ] about
that and I'll tell you this I saw this I
just saw this in one of the comments
this is so good I'm such a Republicans
and gamer and he's doing the smitherso
it's very funny
oh [ __ ] and listen here's the other
thing Adam maybe we want to [ __ ]
maybe we want to shut the [ __ ] up on
until we figure out what would inverse
maybe you're more of an expert at this
but there's no uh there's no audio but
what would make a person do this
oh yeah and there's more what would make
a person do that well I can tell you
what would make a person do that
but first she's like of course I know
him he was me
um
exactly okay your legs hurting there a
little bit buddy your mouth's dry a
little bit you [ __ ] you seem really
thirsty you seem really thirsty why are
you so thirsty